we had a keg
in my car
and i had this little station wagon i
had a a station wagon that was four on
the floor
so it was a
not an automatic station wagon right and
so we used to be able to spin spin tires
and burn rubber and we would do [ __ ]
you should do that in your lexus what
yeah i used to i used to spin out your
tires and alexis going around turning
sometimes
so going to matilah you know how there
was the back street yeah and then there
was milbank yeah so i would go down the
back street and get to matilah and i
would take cruise control off
and i would i would hold the i would put
my foot on the gas and my foot on the
brakes and i would sit there and then i
would take my foot off the brake and let
the tires run and then spin around the
core
in my car
yeah
yep
and mom's
what yeah actually one night when you
guys were out of town riley and i took
mom's car to the uh the fashion square
mall down the street in that parking lot
that's always empty yeah did donuts from
the lexus get the [ __ ] out in the suv
you did not yeah i did riley and i snuck
it yeah really nice knockout that night
we did that well you didn't even sneak
out if we were gone that's true but also
uh we also used to go to the the mall
parking lot when after dark or like when
it closed and we would ride our
longboards through the parking lot and
see who could time it and get down the
fastest
you guys was just did you used to smoke
by the river with that homeless dude not
with the homeless dude anytime i saw the
homeless dude i left how about the dude
remember that dude whose name who called
himself bill and he was always trying to
get
signatures for people to
like for the city to not turn the la
river into a bike path did you ever meet
that guy
no where did you meet him at the river
he was getting signatures by the river
he would walk up and down what i forget
what that street was called by the river
and he would just walk up and down and
anybody who would walk their dog there i
used to walk rock there let me give you
a little background
if
the reason i sound so surprised if
if there were ten pedestrians down that
street every day i would say that was a
busy busy day oh hundred percent and
like and there's just a dude with a
clipboard one no no clipboard he didn't
have anything in hand he would just ask
us for signatures and he would be like
can i get your email and i'd be like
[ __ ] no bill on the back bob one of
those that homeless dude man that guy
was down at that river
but he always in the in the kids puffy
jacket that guy yeah and he had the
barbie slippers on there yeah yeah
he was wearing children's clothing it
was all i could find though so you know
yeah that dude was yeah it was a little
crazy but yeah bill used to every time i
saw him i go bill you talked to me
yesterday he goes did i not go yeah and
my answer is no today just like it was
yesterday have a good day [ __ ] bill
anytime we'd see him i'd try to like
navigate and get out the way but he'd
always like not chase me down but always
follow me wherever i went which was kind
of creepy
[Music]